[Music]
it's great that i think people are
having these
much more much richer i think
relationships with their kids and really
understanding their inner lives
but what happens is we're so worried
about you know
any displeasure that our kids are
experiencing
any you know anxiety or sadness
um you know any of the logical
consequences that come with like you
didn't get the role in the school play
or you didn't get into that college
because you actually didn't work hard or
or just you didn't get into that college
because lots of people applied and
that's what happens in life you're going
to apply for jobs and you might be
completely qualified but
you're not going to get that job but i
think you know parents are
are you know they really have a hard
time tolerating any discomfort that
their children
are experiencing yeah it's not good no
it's not because
a generation of people that that have no
ability to
navigate difficulty in setbacks which
does not set themselves up
well for life right so when i wrote that
article it was because i was doing my
internship and i saw all these people
coming in
right out of college saying my parents
were the best they're my best friends
they
they made everything so easy for me i
have nothing to complain about
and yet i feel unequipped to
be an adult yeah yeah yeah as a parent
your child shouldn't be your best friend
that's that's a a strange violation
of emotional boundaries that it says
more about your needs as a parent than
what's in the child's best interest
right there is this there is i think
this sense especially because
nowadays i think a lot of people are
feeling you know
lonelier because we don't have community
in the same way so in the past
you could walk outside and the kids
would play and the adults would talk and
the kids would be like
doing their own thing and the adults
would be doing their own thing right
like nearby
um but now it's like if you want to have
some kind of social interaction you have
to like make a plan
and it might not necessarily intersect
with your kids plans
um and so we don't have like
neighborhoods community in the same way
a lot of people are really lonely they
don't have a lot of people to talk to
and so what happens is they end up you
know like
getting a lot of emotional gratification
from
being the helicopter parents like you
know we're going to go to music class
now and then we're going to go do this
class
we're going to go do this and because
they don't really have any adult time
yeah um lisa demour and and susan david
both talk about this i mean susan calls
it emotional resilience and
and lisa talks about you know the the
importance of
allowing our kids to fail and putting
them in that position
so that they experience uh how to
develop that kind of resilience at a
young age if
if they're fully formed in their 20s and
they're meeting resistance for the first
time in their lives they're ill-equipped
to
manage it and it causes all kinds of you
know breakdowns and
i think we see that now getting played
out on college campuses
at the moment yeah there's even um i
think it was at the university of
chicago
they have this person at the end of when
you drop off your kid for freshman year
um that the parents weren't willing to
separate from their kids so they said
they had the parents like
go in this one procession to literally
extract
them from their children bouncers you
need to leave right like
all the parents come this way and all
the kids go this way
so the parents can't accompany the kids
to the dorm and like the kids need to go
and meet each other and
bond and do all their freshman
orientation activities and the parents
weren't willing to leave so they
actually have
you know a protocol you know that's laid
out now
that's amazing um and so you know i
think that that says a lot about
how things have changed from one
generation to the next
and it's not that one you know like the
old the old way was better it's just
that i think there's a happy medium
you know like you can you can have this
this rich relationship with your child
but you also have to prepare your child
for adulthood
and you have to have your own life so
many parents nowadays
they don't have a life at all um you
know they don't have a time when like
they are they have their own social life
they're afraid to leave their kids um
you know they they you know their whole
social life
is about you know what am i doing
for where am i where's my kid need to be
at this moment and
and besides the the sort of inability to
navigate
um challenges later in life what are
some of the other uh
you know what is the symptomology that
ends up showing up in these kids later
in life
they can't access their feelings so when
they were sad
um you know let's go to disneyland
or or if something happened that made
them sad like well at lunch so and so
wouldn't sit with me today
the phone call happens to the school
well i understand
them all the time right someone's fixing
their problem for them we're going to
erase your sadness right now we don't
want you to
experience that but the thing is if the
kid could experience that
they could actually problem-solve too
they would come up with a good solution
um or they would experience rejection
which is part of life
and so you say okay what is my kid going
to do well your kid will probably find
other
friends your kid will probably find a
way to
eat lunch with somebody where it's a
comfortable situation and why is that so
difficult for us as parents to take that
step back
i think that part of it is that we
remember how hard it was when we were
kids like if we experienced rejection
and we project that onto our kid yeah
like that's going to scar you
um and and it won't necessarily do that
if you can support your kid and say
that was really that sounds really hard
you know what happened at lunch
um you know and then you just let your
kid talk and they'll come up with
something
but if your kid thinks you're going to
fix it every time every time something
goes wrong they're going to come to you
and say
i'm sad about this i didn't like what
happened here and they're going to
expect that you're going to either give
them a solution or you're going to fix
it you know by calling the school or
calling the other parents with whom they
had a conflict
yeah and then they did they have no
acuity for doing that themselves
right and then they get into the
workplace and what happens is people say
these
kids are like you know they they they
have a sense of entitlement
um you know they don't think that they
should be doing menial tasks
because everyone told them they were so
special and and they were so wonderful
and all of a sudden it's like what do
you mean i need to get you coffee
um you know i i have a college degree
yeah whereas like that was expected
before
that was part of the job you want to
learn the job okay part of it is you're
gonna have to do things that feel
useless yeah but at the same time you're
gonna be
in these meetings yeah so you get the
coffee but you get to sit in that
meeting and learn how to produce that
show or how to negotiate that deal or
whatever you're doing yeah i mean in
your own personal case it's like you
went to yale you went to stanford and
then you became
an assistant in hollywood right and we
don't know what that looks like
yes it was not glamorous i want to talk
about that in a minute but
but to kind of stay on this track so
outside of the helicopter parenting and
the
you know the tiger mom kind of scenario
what about the other side of the
spectrum
like i feel like with my 15 year old
i've given
my wife and i have given her a very long
leash like we're probably on the other
side
of that equation what are the perils of
of too much freedom and allowing this
person
like a very wide birth to experience
their life
you want to give them enough freedom
where
um you know they're ready for it but um
or or maybe they're um you know where
they're comfortable with it
um you want it to come from them too
right so
um you know my son is 13 and
i leave him for periods of time right
meaning like i'll go do something i
might go have
dinner with a friend um and he's doing
his homework at home
um and i'm close by some people say wait
no one's with your your
kid it's like when i was 13 i was
actually babysitting yeah like
you know when i was 13 i was the person
who was taking care of the little kids
in the house
um you know he's perfectly capable of
sitting at home and doing his homework
and and he's a really reliable kid like
i know he's not going to be like playing
fortnite
while i'm gone right um so
you know i mean you want to give them
that like he likes that
and they develop a sense of agency over
their own lives and they feel
yeah and there's a confidence about that
like you know and he likes it he's like
oh no one's here this is really cool
right um he gets to choose how he spends
his time
you know and he knows what is uh he
doesn't just have to do his homework
like he can
he can do other things that what goes
into to
raising that child such that they do
make the choice to do their homework
when you're not there and they're not
on fortnight i think that giving giving
kids freedom makes them more responsible
that if you if you if you're if the
leash is too tight they're going to be
like i never get to do this i have to do
this any minute i get freedom i'm going
to do all these other things
he has enough freedom where you know he
knows
if he has time he'll do his homework um
he wants to do his homework because he
doesn't want to like
you know leave it to the last minute and
then feel stressed so it's about his
stress level
it's for him not for me right um but
he's not just going to sit and do his
homework and he'll do other things like
he might draw or he might
um read a book or he might you know who
knows
he might no he doesn't yeah uh but he
he's getting one this year
um probably i would say like by by
eighth grade
it's gonna be it's gonna be but we have
an interesting we have a contract
you do what tell me what's that so i'm
writing it i'm writing it because we're
in the process of
negotiating getting one um it's just a
contract that's like here it's like one
page it's not like you know
it's kind of like the basic rules like
here's here's what your you've got the
phone for
here's how to use it you know here's how
not to use it
um you know if i find you doing these
things here's what happens to the phone
it's just very clear so there's no
there's no question about sort of like
what's appropriate
certain apps that can be used and others
that can't or
it's not that specific it's kind of like
you know you will
be respectful of people when you use the
phone like you're not gonna
like say mean things about people on
social media or or texting to your
friends like you're not gonna
you're not gonna use it for that purpose
yeah um
you um you know it it doesn't belong
uh you know like after a certain hour it
goes off
um you know basic things about like when
i call you need to answer
right um those kinds of things yeah it's
tough i mean you know i
i struggle with my own attachment and
addiction issues with
the mobile device and i'm seeing it
played out and
in in my kids and particularly my 15
year old daughter like
it's it's just so powerful it has the
capacity to just
override all of your better impulses and
it does hold you hostage so i think the
rules are
super important and then consistently
enforcing them and applying them
right like we don't have phones at the
table ever that just
we don't because we're having a meal
right um you know and i think that
people think that's weird you know that
we're amish or something you know
it's like it's like we're not it's just
that it's it's meal time like why
why should our phones be at the table um
so just things like that but we're not
you know but we use technology i use
technology all the time
so it's not being anti-technology it's
just saying
technology has a place in our lives
but we don't want to drown in it right
[Music]